former FBI director James Comey
testifies tomorrow a source tells CBS
News Comey told Attorney General Jeff
Sessions he did not want to be alone
with the president this followed the
meeting where Comey says the president
asked him not to investigate then
national security adviser Michael Flynn
sources say Comey does not plan to
allege obstruction of justice Senator
Mark Warner of Virginia is the top
Democrat on the Senate Intelligence
Committee he is with us this morning
from Capitol Hill
senator good morning good morning lots
to talk to you about today but first
let's get to the breaking news the
president announcing via Twitter his
choice to be the new FBI director
Christopher ray do you know him I don't
know Christopher ray I hear he's got a
good reputation but clearly this is an
effort by the President to try to
distract attention from our hearings
today and our hearings tomorrow a lot of
the attention is on a lot of the it well
let's see him I think we're going to
hear some pretty interesting things this
morning because not only do we have
reports that the president tried to
intervene with FBI director Comey and
ask him to back off the investigation of
general Flynn which would be totally
inappropriate but we also have reports
that he also asked the Director of
National Intelligence dan coates and the
head of the NSA Admiral Rogers to also
back off or try to downplay the FBI
investigation into mr. Trump and his
affiliates we're going to have a chance
to talk to those gentlemen this morning
if they may try to you know hide a hide
behind executive privilege or legalese
but we're going to press them pretty
hard and if we have today evidence of a
pattern of the president trying to
intervene and then tomorrow with even
more direct evidence when Jim Comey gets
to tell his story I think all of these
efforts to distract the public that the
president may be throwing up frankly
probably aren't going to work if in fact
those things I'll confirm does that
constitute obstruction of justice listen
I'm not that I went to law school but I
never practice today
I will leave that to better legal minds
than me what it would show though is a
really disturbing pattern I mean if
there's one thing we've learned since
Watergate it's not the right role for
the President to intervene in an ongoing
investigation particularly when that
investigation involves potentially the
president and his affiliates what we do
know for sure is this president said
there were no contacts with Russians and
that just isn't true we've had as his
NSA advisor general Flynn resigned
because he didn't tell about the
contacts we've had his attorney general
recused himself because he didn't tell
about contacts with Russians we've had
now one of his closest advisers mr.
Kushner a whole series of contacts why
so many contacts why weren't they
revealed and we also need to figure out
well why is the president trying to back
down this investigation senator warren
'you have said to me and others and
interviews that this is the most
important thing that you have been
involved in we had former DNI mr.
clapper general clapper Admiral clapper
say yesterday in Australia that this is
far worse than Watergate based on your
knowledge so far is it well this has got
more moving parts than Watergate or any
other potential investigation that I am
aware of in modern times there's not a
week that goes by that there's not a new
story about contacts Russian
intervention that really we have to get
to the bottom of it that the good news
is is at least in the Senate
Intelligence Committee we're doing this
in a bipartisan way because the worst
thing that could happen would be if this
committee split and we ended up with a
democratic narrative and a Republican
narrative I don't believe that's going
to happen I think we are going to follow
the facts wherever they lead the center
I just heard you say that you intend to
press them pretty hard today during the
testimony what is your strategy what is
it that you most want to know what I
want to know and I understand that
and I have a great deal of respect for
dan coates he used to be a colleague of
mine on the Intelligence Committee and
Admiral Rogers has served close to 40
years both in the military and as the
head of NSA I understand that they're
active members of this administration
and some of the questions we I'm going
to ask are going to be a bit
uncomfortable but I think in this case
the American public's need to know with
this cloud that hangs over everything
that this administration is doing if
they can help clarify I hope they'll
step up and I think we will have at
least in the case of Admiral Rogers some
other evidence that the call took place
and that there is some memorializing of
that call and that's very very
concerning to me senator one of the
other things we're learning is that
former FBI director Comey told the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions that he
didn't want to be alone with the
President of the United States and yet
the former FBI director didn't tell
anybody in the Justice Department about
that if he believed that the president
was trying to obstruct justice why
didn't he tell the Justice Department
well that's a good question it's a
question that needs to be asked but what
you may have here is a series of
interventions that I believe these
individuals all felt was at least
improper or uncomfortable you just don't
have a sitting president ask about an
ongoing investigation particularly when
that ongoing investigation involves
close associates of the President and if
the president went as far as to say back
off or in the case of general Flynn can
you just let the whole thing go that is
just unacceptable others will make the
decision whether this that crosses some
legal boundary but clearly you know
senator as a former governor I would
never put people who work for me in that
kind of circumstance
senator based on what you know as the
minority of standing as the lord as a
minority member of this committee do you
fear that this goes far more than
anything we have known so far far deeper
core wider I feel like what I thought
most of the time we be
bending would be spent on contacts
between Trump affiliates and associates
and the Russians prior to the election
there's a whole series of interviews and
potential stories that we've not even
gotten to yet because we've also had
this whole series of contacts including
with the Attorney General including with
mr. Kushner that took place between the
election and the swearing-in really
again an unprecedented level of contacts
with a country that at least until
recently has been an adversary in a
country that massively intervened in our
elections and now we've got the series
of interventions by the president with
his top intelligence officials and the
one thing that we pride ourselves in our
cut in this country is that our
intelligence of fesh officials speak
truth to power they are not supposed to
be political and if if we prove out
today that he talked to Rogers Coates
asking them back off and then if we have
Comey coming forward with memos that
that were contemporaneous of it with a
series of conversations from the
president you know in total we're going
to see a pattern here
that even the biggest skeptics is going
to have to set up and say this is very
very serious
senator Warner thank you for joining us
this morning thank you